some breaking news on coronavirus and  surge  testing now at barnet in north london  n3 postcodes are going to be offered  enhanced covid 19  testing after the south african variant  of covert 19 was found  in barnet it's going to start tomorrow  thursday  people fall the variant in specific  postcode areas affected in n3  or those who shop on the local high  street that of course coming  in the week that non-essential shops  were allowed to open and high streets  have got busier  that surge testing will involve both  mobile testing units and also pcr kits  being  delivered door-to-door in certain  postcodes  in n3 in barnet more information  for those in the area on the barnet  borough council website